speaking of the kind of savage saw that
movie a star is born this week oh yeah
was that sad oh dude so [ __ ] yeah my
name Bradley Cooper mm-hmm I didn't want
to see your face one more time I don't
know where this is my Bradley Cooper
voice I couldn't I couldn't get into it
just sound like he was clenching his jaw
okay I'm like a weird ass character okay
I already go home Gaga we can't a lot
you seeing real nice guy go does he have
a southern accent yeah he's like a
southern his name ah dude this [ __ ]
is artist name is Jackson mane okay it
just doesn't to me fit a white dude at
all Jackson me it doesn't matter what's
up me I was Jackson man yeah sounds like
a rapper oh yeah does yeah I'm Bradley
Cooper I'm here to [ __ ] Lady Gaga and
Jackson Miami boy maybe I [ __ ] that
name up I was a myriad as a [ __ ]
but what last night another night
okay.what drunk no no took some yeah
Molly yeah yeah a 2% Molly a little
sweet sweet Molly milk just rolling
balls in the theater so I'm gonna do
take Molly and go to a star is born the
best movie to [ __ ] roll to the Lady
Gaga the was it good at least the movie
no one says it's so good ooh
people who don't watch movies my parents
city egg that's that's it dude I was
just okay I'm a spoiler alert we got a
lot of spoilers here do you care I sorta
care I'm probably gonna see it and I
have no idea what it's about it's like
gonna be one of those movies where I
just go in blind okay I don't know okay
I mean I do want to spoil it like I
don't want you to spoil it though
yeah please and thank you one night in
dicks main okay no Jackson man come on
guy guy I'm [ __ ] dad goddamn it dude
what what are you gonna see this movie
I'm gonna see it eventually I know I
don't like five months from now probably
yeah it's not worth waiting is it in the
theaters right now yeah I'll probably
see it in the theaters [ __ ] okay
fine
[Laughter]
fast forward this part spoiler alert
dude heat okay first of all they add
like this whole other are
to the movie okay which is just so
unnecessary okay he inevitably commits
suicide
oh damn no it's not sad okay it's by
that point in the movie it's been too
long
okay it's like two hours 15 minutes okay
and then they start the suit and you're
just like is it a long-ass movie yeah
and like you see it coming it's not it's
so obvious that he's gonna do it and
there's so much shitty foreshadowing and
then like as he's doing it like the the
scenes of him about to do it it's just
like I'm like just [ __ ] do it man
but I it got to have one I'm like hurry
up I can just kill yourself Jesus Christ
it was just it was so not it was so
uneventful and like so not needed okay
the story to me makes no [ __ ] sense
okay he finds Gaga singing in this bar
and he's just like hey I'm famous
[ __ ] I [ __ ] like you and then he
brings her out to a show and he hears
her sing one time in a parking lot then
at his show he's like Oracle model stage
and sing that thing I remember that
thing you did knock came a little tune
for it and she goes out there and sings
her balls off and becomes like she does
that she does this whole like pop star
arc which like whatever man she's not
like it you know and then he is an
alcohol problem oh no so roughly in the
film he just falls off it's not shown
it's not really described or explored he
just now he's falling off okay he's also
got kidness tignous fitness so he can't
like that what is didn't it's like when
you're [ __ ] and like you're [ __ ]
some titties and yeah that's what it
sounds like a [ __ ] didn't it
it sounds like titty nice yeah that's
not all girls we got a titmouse kidness
they got a tetanus right now I got no
tip nice Jackson Maine like so little
bit tedious didn't s so I like you got
go get that tetanus like some [ __ ] up
how do declare
exclude lady gaga you got that tipnis my
god Bob darling damn down tetanus sound
like it scared listen you got like
ringing in your ear okay I think I have
it
it's this podcast [ __ ] has it all the
time yeah persistent a murder that's
stupid noise yeah he's got persistent
ringing he's got an alcohol problem okay
it's not sad okay so then at some point
she like when gentleness she wins an
award for her music and he like gets
drunk as [ __ ] and she goes on stage to
like get she brings him on stage which
is first of all you knew she
acknowledges like two minutes before
that they each piss-drunk okay but she
still drags his dumb ass on stage or
down the carpet to go with her on stage
and what does he do uh well she goes up
to like received the award and then he
kind of like falls just before this the
stage like on the stairs and he's like
I'm gonna just sit right here I'm just
right here cuz he's drunk as [ __ ] and
it's supposed to be set like in LA
mm-hmm like it's half it's 80% reality
it might as well have just been Bradley
Cooper and Lady Gaga made up a story
it's just not like them cell playing
themselves yeah playing uh hold
ourselves it's still weird it's the
goofiest [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you know
and by the way this is the second movie
where Bradley Cooper is just like a dude
with a nice smile and means well but has
some kind of addiction some issue like
silver linings was it he's like angry in
that movie you know he had uh like pills
yeah but he was like mint he had he had
like bipolar or something like that
yeah okay move that doesn't count then
yeah I thought didn't that I forgot out
he was like mentally ill I thought in
that movie I don't know yeah
this is [ __ ] though he just was on
alcohol that was mentally ill he had a
mental disorder I don't know what the
proper term is whatever have fun okay so
I'm wrong whatever um anyway so he's
just sitting there he's like ow and she
while she's receiving the award
he's jabbering on the side and I'm like
if there was ever a setting or someone
who is pissed drunk and collapses to his
ass right before the stage would be
jumped on by fifteen little men with
headsets on it's definitely bad
why the only way Kanye got away with is
cuz he bolted past them yeah he ran in
front of the cameras and that's like
that's like you know the sidewalk like
crack yeah he was standing on the crack
and all the producers then we're like
[ __ ] we're gonna lie out fire we can't
we can't go up there
yeah so you just didn't think it's
unrealistic hey just the bottom of the
stairs just talking for like three
minutes left how did you win the award
did you win I better get out I better
get on up there so it's like those be
embarrassing for him yeah but it's not
it just and this is what I was leading
up to it just ends up being savages [ __ ]
because he gets up there and he's so
drunk isn't give a [ __ ] about the show
he just starts admiring the set oh man
look at you up there dang oh Jesus
bright any kind of steps for and you
stand there's a drunk as [ __ ] it's
pretty savage it is and then he pisses
himself Oh what yeah [ __ ] legend yeah
it was hard it wasn't like it I didn't
watch that and go oh god I'm like this
fool is [ __ ] a rockstar this dude
rules this guy was [ __ ] dope up there
pissing himself not caring how about
that he's on stage at the end
girlfriends winning an award he's
justhe's wife they're dating in the mill
in the movie I'm married yeah okay I no
need to watch this movie anymore
it's it sucks dude it's not good okay it
sucks alright alright that's the best
scene right there when he's just like
peeing himself and he's just like I said
I was talking about this [ __ ] dude goes
I kind of want to see this now just to
watch him here he himself
you know I don't see that do now yeah
but it's like it's not worth you can
just go rent it okay you'll forget about
all this is your memories yeah yeah it's
shitty trust me now with all this bleach
just soaked into my brain dude yeah
[ __ ] trust me I got nothing left
I've got some clothes
[Music]
is that Dustin club these are custom
pump these are Dustin home these are